do you all have any reason to believe
that uaps
and or what may be behind them may
intervene at some point to prevent
nuclear holocaust or some large iniquity
for example with russia
i personally don't have any evidence of
that we've uh we have a
great deal of evidence that they didn't
stop the testing of the first device the
use of it twice
and the subsequent testing by numerous
nations on the earth during that period
of time so i don't see why they would
intervene otherwise i don't have any
evidence to point towards uh any kind of
motive
i can't even identify uh
who's behind the craft so getting to
their motives would be a very hard very
much longer stretch
yeah i'll go i'll go even even a little
more pointed than that um look they did
nothing they didn't interfere with
chernobyl they didn't interfere with
fukushima uh they didn't interfere with
uh the vaporization of 500 000 people uh
during world war ii uh hiroshima
nagasaki they didn't interfere during
the cuban missile crisis they didn't
appear
uh right now in the ukraine so
so the question is uh is there any
evidence to substantiate that they're
here to stop mankind from from uh
hurting ourselves well they haven't
stopped coving they haven't stopped
climate change they haven't stopped
world war ii korean war or anything else
and they haven't stopped world hunger so
um
you know i i it'd be nice if that was a
case but i haven't seen any evidence to
suggest that what i have seen is
evidence to suggest of some sort of isr
intelligent surveillance reconnaissance
of our nuclear equities and technology
that we have seen we've been able to
substantiate that and the ability to
interfere with it but the question is
are they interfering it for good well
right now there's no information to
indicate that at least not from my my
perspective do you have any idea what
this cataclysm is that people like ross
coldheart refer to
and if you do has it been is it
impending has it been averted
i think i understand um what ross is
talking about i've spoken to ross at
length uh
privately
there's
i know what ross is talking about from
the side of um
of the coin where i where i work and
where i'm interested in the subject i
have no connection to it whatsoever
other than as i often say the pop site
geist ufology now that's not to say that
i haven't studied some of the same
things that uh that ross has and other
people like grant cameron and others
that there is a cyclical nature to uh to
life on earth that there are changes
evident in the fossil record and in
sedimentary records
um and things like that so
there may be a great deal of conflation
going on here between what we call the
entertainment aspect of ufology and the
need to
um invigorate a subject and keep people
interested in it vice the actual nuts
and bolts again
and the reality of it um species have
gone extinct before there's no reason to
expect that we won't go extinct someday
uh so when people talk about cataclysms
i think it's important that we don't
conflate them with um with popupology
i'd like to leave that to the geologists
and to the climatologists and the other
people who are who are making that their
specific focus
um i i you know i could i'm not sure
precisely what you're referring to i
mean cataclysms have always been
been part of of of human evolution um
you know in fact one could argue we've
always been on the verge of a cataclysm
at any moment our species
there have been been historical
anecdotes whether it's nostradamus or
the mayan calendar or even the bible or
the bhagavad-gita or anything else
you know
cataclysm armageddon whatever has always
been part of of
of
the human
storytelling
and for good reason because you do have
these these uh moments in time where
where things change so dramatically case
in point one could probably point to
to uh the last ice age where where when
when the earth was thawing out of the
ice age that was a major moment
and caused a lot of species you know to
to to disappear because because
environments change uh the land bridge
when that uh was no longer crossable you
isolated certain uh genetic species
from from intermingling with each other
um you know
it's it's always been part of of who we
are and always part of earth because
earth changes right look at the
dinosaurs right and and that was a hell
of a cataclysm right when you had uh
you had a meteor come down and white
about 90 of of animals on this planet um
that's just reality that's not you know
i'm not sure that's necessarily
something we all need to
to to look at and say oh you know that's
coming we've we've always been
immersed in that again you can look
throughout history and see where mankind
in almost every religious text there is
some sort of reference to some sort of
cataclysmic event or that has occurred
or will occur whether it's the flooding
stories of the earth and the 40 days of
of of rain uh or other you know
pick your pick your story right um that
we have always been telling ourselves
and the things continue to happen world
war iii just another example right um
nuclear war
it's always it's always right around the
corner and for good reason because you
have
a lot of things operating in nature that
aren't necessarily in favor for a
species survival and so you have to
adapt if you want to survive whether
that's climate or or because of things
we do to each other
that's just the reality of life so i'm
not aware of any particular cataclysm
uh
story you're maybe referring to because
frankly
you know pick your story to journal